what's the secret to making it work in
Hollywood for you guys to making what
making the relationship the marriage
work oh I don't know we the key to a
perfect marriage Seth Rogen and wife
Lauren Miller not only bring the comedy
to their marriage they've also used
humor to put the spotlight on
Alzheimer's awareness the couple started
hilarity for charity after watching her
mom suffer from the disease the pair was
honored at varieties third annual unite
for Humanity event on Thursday we both
have been so active in your crusade to
really find a cure for Alzheimer's but
how do you manage to balance bring in
comedy while also talking about such a
serious issue I hope we do manage it
I like the assumption that we do with
them that goes along with that question
um I mean I think just being honest it
helps we try to make events that are fun
and funny because we know how not funny
Alzheimer's is and we're trying to
counteract that in some way I think by
really you know distracting people from
it I feel like people really are
starting to talk about it the stigma is
starting to go away and you know the
government did increase funding a little
bit in the fall not nearly what it needs
to be but it was a step in the right
direction